the devil's candy is written and
directed by Sean Byrne who also wrote
and directed the loved ones which was a
bit of a cult hit this film is about a
struggling painter who gets a new house
with his family a young daughter and his
wife and suddenly he starts to hear
weird sounds and his paintings start to
drastically change from beautiful
butterflies to weird creatures and
screaming children and he doesn't know
exactly what's going on when he paints
he loses time to leave his studio and
realize it's nighttime at the same time
there just might be a crazy guy on the
loose killing people with rocks hmm
and it's good I saw this movie on Amazon
I rented it I was going to watch it
entirely for leisure purposes and I
enjoyed this film so much that I
couldn't help but turn on the camera
instantly and start to talk about it
this movie is one of the better
independent horror films I've seen in a
long time for one the cinematography is
absolutely gorgeous no lighting the
position of the characters in the frame
whether they're in the foreground or the
background the way he cuts shots
together to create almost a subliminal
effect of being in some form of trance
this movie had me in its grasp from
pretty much the beginning this is a very
short film it's about 79 minutes long
and I would say that after about the 10
to 15 minute mark I was pretty much
riveted all the way to the end this has
a really good opening as well with a
fantastic and very underrated actor who
is often typecast now that man is Pruitt
Taylor Vince who plays a very very
deranged person in this film you may
recognize him from the show the x-files
he was in an episode he was in the movie
identity the movie heavy he tends to
play very similar characters and he
knocks it out of the park in this movie
because just about every time he walked
on frame he just gave me chills it's
just he's such an unsettling presence in
this film and a lot of it does have to
do with the fantastic editing also I
really have to give major major props to
ethan embry this performance kind of
blew me away he is cut to shit in this
movie and he often paints in underwear
and he's got all these tats and he just
looks so aggressive
and he's so terrifying in the way that
he approaches his art once he starts to
hear these voices and they affect him
and you kind of be the sense of what's
going on I don't want to get into it
because I honestly started watching this
movie without knowing what it was about
it just looked promising and it had some
pretty good reviews and so I was like
all right just watch this thing so I
don't really want to give you too many
hints about what's going on underneath
the surface but I can basically say
there's a creepy house some shit happen
there once and now this guy is painting
faces and he doesn't know why and at the
same time there's a lot of family drama
because he's losing time as I said when
he starts painting in this studio and
sometimes he forgets the
responsibilities that he has to do with
his daughter and his wife and Byrne is
really smart to recognize that the best
horror films aren't always about
monsters or vampires they're usually
about some form of psychological trauma
something very basic that every human
deals with just amplified my favorite
horror film of all time is the shining
and if you've seen the shining you know
that you know towards the last 10
minutes Jack Nicholson grabs an axe and
it becomes a horror movie but up until
then it's mostly very psychological most
of the horror in the shining is really
about a father who's neglecting his
family because he's getting so sucked
into his work and then there's this
crazy otherworldly force that is causing
all these problems for him that's now
amplifying the terror of his normal
family trauma and when you really look
at the devil's candy it's very similar
in that way you have a painter who's
getting far too into his job and there's
some forces at work and it's causing him
to neglect his family and so you could
look at that and say well it's kind of
similar but it's just pulled in a
different way but all the best horror
films are like this they understand that
the things that truly are scary are not
necessarily these crazy creatures and
monsters and ghosts but what if
something was just controlling you and
it was making you neglect your family
that's kind of terrifying and you can
relate to that all the performances
across the board are really fantastic in
this film the last five minutes get a
little ridiculous but it was a
ridiculous that I appreciated and almost
respected I don't know
it's this is weird for me this year with
a cure for wellness personal shopper and
now the devil's candy I'm seeing all
these weird fucked up movies and I'm I'm
liking them a lot like I don't I like
weird shit I guess and as I said it is a
very short film it's about 79 minutes
and I feel like it could have benefited
from probably about 15 more minutes of
character building character depth for
this family just a little more weight to
be given to these characters so that
when shit starts getting really real
towards the end you can really feel it
but the direction and the editing was so
strong and ethan embry is so friggin
good in this movie that it really sold
that entire third act even though I
would have liked to have seen a little
more character depth I'm going to give
the devil's candy and a - as an
independent horror film that I knew
nothing about just going into this movie
it kind of floored me it's really well
directed I strongly recommend checking
it out it's available for rental on a
lot of online platforms right now and it
is in some theaters as well guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you liked this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]